Mind your decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar
The square ABCD has a side length equal to ten. Suppose E is the midpoint of the side AD
Fold the square from the vertex A
Along the line segment EB in such a way that the point a becomes the point F
The question is what is the distance from the point F to the line segment DC?
I thank Ankit and Amlan for the suggestion
Pause the video, if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
There are many ways to solve this problem and I will present three different methods
Let's get started by using similar triangles
First since E is the midpoint of the side AD we have that AE is equal to five
Next consider the right triangle AEB. We can calculate its hypotenuse EB using the Gougu Theorem
EB is equal to the square root of five squared plus 10 squared, which means
EB is equal to five times the square root of five
Construct AF. Let its intersection with the line EB be the point G
Since E is equidistant from the points A and F and B is equidistant from the points A and F
EB is the perpendicular bisector of AF
Consequently, these line segments are perpendicular
From here triangle AGE must be similar to triangle BAE
These are both right triangles that share an equal angle. Therefore we can equate the ratio of the hypotenuse to the longer side
This means EA over AG is equal to EB over BA
We substitute in the values and then we solve for AG
We simplify to get AG is equal to 10 divided by the square root of 5
Now what's the length of GF
Well AG and GF are equal to each other because EB is the perpendicular bisector of AF
Therefore GF is equal to 10 divided by the square root of 5
now let's construct FH this creates another right triangle and
It shares an angle with the right triangle AGE
therefore AHF is similar to the right triangle AGE
But from before AGE is similar to the right triangle BAE
therefore
AHF is similar to the triangle BAE
This means we have the following ratios that are equal
From here we substitute in the known values and we can simplify and solve for AH
We get that AH is exactly equal to 8
Now AD, the entire side of the square is equal to 10
AH plus HD must be equal to 10 and this means HD is equal to 2
But HD is exactly equal to the distance from F to the line segment, DC
Therefore the distance from F to the line segment DC is equal to 2. And that's our answer
Let's now move to the next method of using coordinate geometry
we will first set up a coordinate system will run the x-axis through the bottom side of the square and we'll run the
Y-axis through the left side of the square we can then describe the coordinates of some of these points
The upper corner of the square will be equal to 10 comma 10 because each side of the square has a length equal to 10
Let's now describe the equation for a line that passes through these two points
notice that the line that passes through these two points will have a slope equal to 1/2 and we already know that the
Y-intercept is equal to 5
therefore we have the equation 1/2 x + 5
We then want to describe the equation of the line that goes through the point 0 10 and F
Notice that since these two lines are perpendicular
The slope of this line will be the negative reciprocal of the first line
So the slope of this line will be equal to negative 2 and we know it's y-intercept is equal to 10
So this line will have an equation that's equal to -2x + 10
To find the intersection of these two lines
We set the equations equal to each other and we can readily solve that X is equal to 2 and Y is equal to 6
Now this point will exactly be the midpoint between 0 10 and F
Suppose F has the coordinates of P and Q
We thus have 10 + Q, all over 2 is equal to 6
This means Q is equal to 2 and that's exactly the vertical distance
Therefore the distance from F to the line segment DC is equal to 2
Well now move on to the third method of trigonometry
To get started recall that the hypotenuse EB has a length equal to five times the square root of five
Then triangle AEB is congruent to triangle FEB
This means FB has a side length equal to ten
from here suppose angle ABE is equal to theta that means angle EBF is also equal to theta
Now construct FP that's perpendicular to the side AB
consider this triangle
The sin of two theta will be equal to FP
divided by ten
We can then use the sin double angle formula from here
We need to calculate the sin of theta and the cos of theta which we can readily get from the triangle ABE
We calculate the values for sin of theta and cos of theta and substitute those into the formula
We then simplify and we will solve that FP is equal to eight
Now FP is equal to eight but the entire vertical distance is equal to the side of the square
Consequently the distance from F to the side DC is equal to two, just as before
It's a very interesting problem that you can solve in many different ways
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support